good morning John I just got back to the
North American International Auto Show
in Detroit Michigan and while I was
there I wrote a song about it do you
want to hear here it goes the North
American International Auto Show
it promises the biggest in the best
that's why I always go but this time
something's different something has
changed I walked through these aisles of
cards and hunted something strange
this one doesn't tower over me
and this one couldn't even fit a family
of six she you know what is the point of
a car the came to abode up a 90 degree
slope in the middle of a tornado
oh all I wants a v8 Hemi weigh in 8,000
pounds of it where's any getting two or
three gallons to the mile
but I look around such a pity all these
cars are itty-bitty and they just aren't
worth my time
if I wanted to drive a tiny car I'd live
in France
I'd be a commie and my wife would be
hairy and I'd wear ridiculous pants the
Mini Cooper makes me feel physically
unwell and a smart car belongs in the
seventh circle of hell I want a car I
can use to win a war in Southeast Asia
and need stairs to get up and no and it
comes to my next car I won't buy for
don't satisfy like a sir sighs burger
and fry oh all I wants a v8 Hemi weight
8,000 pounds if it was any getting two
or three gallons to the mile
but I looked around and shot your pity
all these cars are really bitty and they
just aren't worth my
all I wants a v8 Hemi weigh in 8,000
pounds of it weighs any getting 2 or 3
gallons to the mine
such a pity all these cars are
itty-bitty 56 miles per gallon in the
city and gather swans kind of pretty but
I'm sure they're all totally me and they
just aren't worth my time
yeah I'll actually talk about what I saw
they got a show later on this week but
this is the return of song Wednesdays
and John I think next Tuesday I'm gonna
follow your lead and go through some
wild journals I'm pretty sure that I
have some in fact I'm gonna go check
real quick oh this one looks promising
this weekend kicked ass I went to Katie
a me and Nicole's party at Louis's house
and we partied till like 11:00 then
there's this startling observation
people get upset when you tell them that
you wouldn't cry if they died hope I
didn't learn that through experience
okay well we're gonna go through this a
little bit more on Tuesday John I'll see
you on Sunday